do you guys know who casey neistat is
the youtuber yes very very popular
youtuber huge he actually tweeted over
the weekend saying that he was in la and
the car that he was driving got broken
into a lot of his stuff was stolen he
then blasted la for being a [ __ ] of
a city he thanked the lapd for
recovering his stuff and finding the
person who broke into his car seth rogen
found this and said that it has nothing
to do with la and everything to do with
him leaving his [ __ ] in his car so
you're nuts it's lovely here don't leave
anything valuable it's called living a
big city yeah and i guess after that he
got some backlash from casey neistat
fans but he got lit up just in general
who did seth rollins
[ __ ] dumbass he's bit of a oh
something that's really important to
realize and i got this from rogan's
podcast with tristan harris is that a
lot of this stuff on on twitter is uh is
troll farms yeah so so they they do this
on purpose they so a lot of the [ __ ]
you're talking to some of these dms are
not even real people but this is real
this is actually this one seth rogen yes
i mean you know it's like go [ __ ] off
but seth rogen yeah people were like
dude how privileged are you for a guy a
kid to get his [ __ ] car broke into
you like yeah deal with big city [ __ ]
it's like [ __ ] out of here man yeah
yeah it is a [ __ ] and it is crime
riddled and and go [ __ ] yourself not
crazy [ __ ] it's also it's also
seth rogen speaking about this in his
mansion in bel air that's where it gets
dicey yeah you think yeah got it okay he
does also refer to like him being broke
and getting his car uh broken into 20
times within his time in l.a he's saying
it's not that big of a deal it happens
and by the way i'm sorry you're also
here for two months and got ridiculously
famous by sucking off uh he's [ __ ]
judd
right he's been famous bro and he's not
that good i'm sorry
i think what does rogan do to you i
think he's
he's okay down okay he's all right i
like him i think he's all right i like
seth rogen yeah i think he's i don't
like
he's becoming like such a woke [ __ ] but
i think i guess i don't know much about
him because i'm like oh i didn't think
he was he's got he's very chubby and he
plays that beta male very well and
that's fine and i'm sure he's he's not a
bad guy
i in fact in fact i happen to know maybe
i'm speaking out of turn but i happen to
know that he the money he made off of
renting his very expensive apartment in
vancouver he gave he would use that
money for charity he's not a bad guy
this is not seth rogen's not a bad guy
but he's just a little out of touch yeah
a little bit out of touch
this shows that
yeah
that's like casey ness that he can
probably uh afford casey neistat dude is
doing very well he's fine yeah they're
both rich oh so we're talking about
ballers
this is too rich guys aren't you yeah
yeah
i get why he's upset about saying stuff
about l.a though right now why did why
did seth rogen people always
uh what's dak shepard's girl's name
kristen bell christian bell took a
picture with that oh yeah the sheriff
ella county sheriff's sheriffs and
people just lit her up for it what a
surprise
so so so can i ask
why why is it that the more woke you are
the more into masks and and against the
police you are and also why is it that
you usually don't live in a neighborhood
that is riddled with crime you wouldn't
drive through the neighborhoods you're
talking about much less no they [ __ ]
never so you know what i'm saying so
yeah i know exactly it does become
political it's like
they're so out of touch i'm seth rogen
it's like dude just [ __ ]
just do your job and shut the [ __ ] up